um okay well welcome everyone um to um
another uh dissertation defense in our
program
and um we actually have a couple more
coming up this summer that you all
should have gotten appointments for so
um i am pleased to
introduce lilly cook who
to most of you on the call needs no
introduction she's been around the
department for a number of years
and this is the um final public step
on her way um to achieving her phd
um
lily um well well and so then just just
to let those of you um
who aren't familiar with know how our
dissertations work i say this every time
but i'll say it again um
basically lilly will give a presentation
um and then um
we will open up to the public all
participants on the call free to ask any
questions
at that point the public will be
dismissed and she'll remain with her
committee who may have some additional
questions for her and then she will be
dismissed from the committee and then
the committee will determine whether or
not she has successfully
defended her dissertation so
lily as you all know is a
is a national library medicine fellow
actually also
actually funded by some separate funding
we got from the national institutes for
environmental health sciences
and um
she's
pursuing her phd with that fellowship
in terms of her past she received a
bachelor of arts in psychology and
sociology from wesleyan university
then received a master of arts in
counseling from george fox university
and was in
practice private practice as a
psychotherapist for a number of years
until she joined our program and decided
or decided to pursue a phd and then
joined our program and so um this is the
last step well the last public step if
she successfully defends her thesis she
will then um need to write up her thesis
and then at which point um we can call
her dr cook
so um take it away lily
okay thank you bill
so thank you all for coming and today
i'm going to be presenting my
dissertation work on data quality and
social determinants of health
so this is an important topic because
there continue to be disparities in
health care and health outcomes and the
covet 19 pandemic has really driven home
the relationship between health inequity
and poor health outcomes in fact just
about every metric that we look at with
regard to covet 19 confirms that we
still have a lot of work to do to remedy
these disparities whether we're looking
at covet case rates or hospitalization
rates or death rates or whether we're
looking at access to vaccines
in order to document and better
understand all the complicated factors
that create these disparities we need
good data specifically we need good data
about social determinants of health
so there are numerous definitions of
social determinants of health the center
for disease control and prevention
relies upon what they call a place based
framework for their definition and they
state that social determinants of health
are conditions in the places where
people live learn work and play that
affect a wide range of health risks and
outcomes and they add that most health
and equity can be traced back to these
social determinants factors both amia
and the national library of medicine
have been emphasizing social
determinants recently because of how
much these non-clinical factors and
contexts influence patient health but
now that we've been using social
determinants data more and more
frequently it's become more clear that
the state is often very messy and we
don't have many
and who haven't
formalized ways to prove it
if we're not controlling the quality of
data that we really can't know for sure
then any conclusions we draw from it are
valid
so the quality of social determinants of
health data is an important issue
because bad data can cause problems with
bias reliability and validity and health
equity research
my work moves us towards solutions to
those problems by furthering the
development of methods for improving the
quality of the social determinants of
health data that's used in health equity
research
and i approached this problem by
focusing on data quality improvement
practices for real-world data
particularly looking at the data
preparation process
so my first aim
was to identify the data quality issues
specific to social determinants of
health variables sourced from the ehr
and this aim resulted in an article that
was published in jamia
and i fulfilled this aim with a
systematic literature review
or as i put it i read 250 articles about
social determinants of health so you
don't have to
so
here's what i found
this table gives a breakdown of the
content analysis that i conducted as
part of that review and that content
analysis showed that articles about race
and ethnicity variables have the largest
body of literature
so my first major finding is that the
quality of data about race and ethnicity
is an important topic with a large body
of literature
and the literature also showed that bias
or validity issues often result from
data quality problems so a majority of
articles either found bias when running
test analyses on their data sets or they
noted that data quality was
differentially poor for certain groups
meaning that there was a high potential
for bias during analysis
and these data quality problems are not
distributed randomly across groups data
about hispanic race ethnicity is
especially prone to bias
the most common
commonly identified problem with race
and ethnicity data was misclassification
which showed up in 19 articles
and 14 of those studies reported that
hispanic patients were more likely to be
misclassified
six found disproportionately high rates
of misclassification for american
indians compared to other racial groups
and the second most common problem with
racism the sea data is that it's
differentially incomplete in other words
it's missing not at random or mnr
so data missing non-randomly like that
means that it has a high potential for
bias
so major finding number two here is that
problems encountered with the quality of
social determinants of health data are
rarely distributed randomly certain
groups are more prone to data quality
issues and this is especially true for
hispanic patients but we also saw this
with data from american indians
so another major finding of the
literature review was that although
there are problems with data quality
there are also solutions that can
mitigate those issues 62 percent of the
articles in the literature review made
at least one evidence-based
recommendation for users seeking to
improve the quality of social
determinants data after it had been
collected so i group those
recommendations into six suggestions
which are shown here
you know the first one is to avoid
complete case analysis and kind of along
the same lines you know impute missing
data
um also number three is to rely on
multiple sources of data
which i call triangulating the data
also number four is to use validated
software tools
arcgis showed up a lot in that review
and select addresses thoughtfully
and
six be transparent
about any data quality problems
so major finding number three from
specific aim one is that
the literature contains suggestions on
improving data quality so there are
problems but there are also ways to
mitigate those problems
and there were findings about social
determinance factors other than race and
ethnicity in this review
i also found that problems can arise
with everything that's in that orangish
color there
which is information that's derived by
linking individual level medical records
to community level variables like air
quality or neighborhood socioeconomic
status in order to do that we match the
patient's home address to information
about their neighborhood which is called
geocoding and the literature review
revealed that a couple of different
problems can arise with that data
primarily that rural data can be
problematic and that environmental
exposures can be misclassified
and the last major finding from specific
aim 1 is that
environmental and community level social
determinants data which relies on
geocoding it can have problems due to
issues with matching and linkage for
example rural data can be problematic
so my subsequent aims were informed by
the findings from aim 1
and i developed the research project for
the second aim around a unique
opportunity that i had to work with the
data and the national profit cohort
collaborative or n3c
and this paper that i wrote to fulfill
aim2 was a collaboration with several
members of the national covet cohort
collaborative
social determinants of health domain
team
and i presented
this at the amia informatics summit in
chicago in march and the full-length
manuscript is currently in review with
jmir medical informatics
so the national covid cohort
collaborative data enclave or n3c is the
largest collection of patient-level cova
data in the u.s and one of the largest
such collections in the world
at the time that we conducted this
research the n3c contained data from 6.5
million patients tested for codavid19
that had been collected by 56 healthcare
systems across the united states and the
database has grown larger since then
and i refer to working with n3c as a
unique opportunity because the fact that
this is a centralized database with data
from healthcare systems all over the
united states meant that we could show
how the findings from my first aim
generalized across different health care
systems
so
the background here is that each of
these 56 health care systems
contributing their data to the m3c has a
slightly different way of recording and
encoding that data
so if you just dumped all of the raw
data from these different healthcare
systems into a centralized database and
you tried to do research on that the
data would be too noisy for any useful
signals to emerge
so to make this data usable has to be
transformed
prior to that multiple times and the
process of transforming the data to a
common data model in order to make it
usable it's called mapping or
harmonizing the data so to harmonize the
data hundreds of different encodings get
distilled down to just a handful of
concepts
and the national cohort collaborative
data enclave keeps the original source
data essentially as it's given to them
by the contributing healthcare systems
and they keep it alongside that
harmonized mapped data so the harmonized
data is what's intended for research use
although the source data is also
available to researchers
so centralized data like this is more
usable if everyone
uses data standards when they're
collecting the data in the first place
because
standardized data doesn't require as
many transformations and that's why we
have standards
and yes there are standards for race and
ethnicity data the most commonly used
standard is the federal standard which
is shown here and then this is
essentially how that data is supposed to
be structured according to the federal
government and the national academy of
medicine and hl7 so there are five
minimum categories for race which are
shown here
on that left column and then ethnicity
is shown in the center column and that's
a separate concept from race
ethnicity only refers to hispanic or
latino ancestry essentially how the
standard's supposed to be implemented is
that everybody has a race which is one
of those five categories and also an
ethnicity uh hispanic latino or not
hispanic latino and then there's more
granular subcategories of race and
ethnicity that can roll up into these
larger primary categories
so for example you could select a more
detailed answer like vietnamese
but for tabulation purposes that
subcategory should roll up into adhesion
so this is how the healthcare
institutions are supposed to be
structuring their data
which seems clear enough like i guess
but
we know there are all these data quality
problems
with race and ethnicity data so what's
actually happening
so this table shows all the harmonized
categories for race that are in the n3c
in order from largest to smallest and
you'll notice that the second largest
category was no matching concept which
suggests that a significant amount of
the data about patient rays got lost at
some point in the data pipeline
and you can see here that some clinical
sites are still using
outdated deprecated concepts such as
non-white which is number 16 here
and you can also see how even though
this is the harmonized data these
cohorts are still a little bit fractured
for example
black should have been mapped to black
or african american and there are some
other categories here like other pacific
islander and native hawaiian or other
pacific islander that also should have
been combined so this is called the
heterogeneity problem and it's a problem
because anyone who might
be running a query on this database
like maybe they're trying to build a
table one for a research paper or build
a cohort of black or african american
people in order to understand why that
group has much higher hospitalization
rates with omicron
they're probably going to pull the
information from one of these groups and
then completely miss the other group
or at best
they're going to have to spend a lot of
extra time harmonizing the data on their
own rather than actually studying covid
so either these fractured groups are
creating a lot of noise
in your data or best case scenario you
have this rate limiting factor of having
to spend extra time harmonizing the data
and doing the mappings yourself
so next i delved into would have been
labeled as data that had no matching
concept which i called non-conforming
data because it doesn't conform to the
federal standard and to look at this
i aggregated each category
by the source values and i tabulated
those results
in order to find out how many patients
have been given each encoding and how
many ways each category was reported and
then i cross tabulated those resulting
categories by patient ethnicity
by data partner and by data model
and then we used an inductive approach
to sort the non-conforming data into
these categories
so
this non-conforming data with no
matching category
a lot of the time everything those
categories
which is things like other or missing
it's considered unusable and it's often
ignored or dropped by data users so what
that means is that when we create
cohorts by race anybody in those
categories will be excluded
and the bottom line here is that this is
how you know erasure can really
inadvertently happen with data
the people in those categories are not
going to show up in an analysis or in
the results and
a lot of times they get omitted from
research and again that's not
necessarily a big deal if it's happening
to all groups equally
but remember from that first study i did
the literature review
it seems probable based on the
literature that there's going to be a
disproportionate number of hispanic
latino and american indian people
in this group of unusable non-conforming
data that has no matching category
and guess what yes so the main findings
with this study were that yes as in the
literature review hispanic people were
over represented in this non-conforming
race data as were american indian and
alaska native people and black or
african american people to various
degrees and we could kind of reconstruct
how that had happened and how people had
wound up in these categories and
actually each of those three groups had
ended up there for very different
reasons so the data from the american
indian alaska native population for
example was deliberately obscured by the
n3c by being placed in the other
category
but the good news is that we could
rescue some of the data and we can make
it usable again and return at least some
people to their cohorts
so this is a sankey diagram that i made
to show how the findings of this study
might be applied
the data could be rescued or essentially
transformed to be more usable
and it's possible to correct the data
from over 45 000 patients that have been
improperly mapped
when compared to examining race alone
combining race and ethnicity into a
single unified category not only allowed
the hispanic latino population to be
better represented but it also allowed
us to decrease missingness of race data
by 13.6 percent and reduced reduce
refused responses by 21
and reduce the amount of data in the
other race category by 61 percent
so moving on to aim three
so for this final aim i wanted to apply
those findings from aim 1 to show
that these methods for improving data
quality
have a direct and measurable impact on
study results and i wanted to use a
geocoded
integrated or linked
linked data set to explore that so i
decided that i would accomplish that by
studying my own study
so a couple of years ago i designed and
carried out a cohort study in which i
looked at the association between
pulmonary exacerbations and people with
cystic fibrosis and poor air quality
days caused by wildfire smoke
and for that study i'd used geocoded
patient addresses to link an individual
level health outcome
documented in the clinical record
in this case pulmonary exacerbations
with a community level exposure in this
case poor air quality days caused by
wildfire smoke
and that was a pretty straightforward
cohort study that was published in the
journal of pediatric pulmonology
but i was curious about all the choices
i'd made when transforming that data for
analysis and all of those
uh dozens of judgment calls that i made
so what if i'd made different choices
would i have gotten different
results
and
and
i was curious about that because when
we're preparing data for analysis or
data munching or data wrangling whatever
your preferred term for the data
preparation process is while we're doing
that we're making choices about how to
clean transform and integrate the data
and making choices about data quality
issues like how to handle missing or
inaccurate data
data preparation is really the action
step for improving data quality
so to study this i developed an
algorithm which prepared the data from
my study on wildfire smoke and cystic
fibrosis a variety of different ways i
took those prepared data sets and i
generated results from them using
fisher's exact test
so to build that algorithm i broke the
data preparation process i used into
four discrete steps
and the first step was validated
was to validate the addresses of the
patients in the data set because i
needed their addresses to assign each
patient their readings from the air
quality monitor closest to where they
lived the second step was dealing with
missing addresses
for the same reason in order to match
patients to information about air
quality
and next i matched the health
information from each patient with
information from the air quality monitor
readings closest to them and thus
integrating the two data sets
because air quality monitor readings are
only relevant within a certain radius
next i had to decide how far away a
patient could live from the nearest air
quality monitor and still be included in
the study
and finally
i decided how long it might take after
an exposure for a patient to develop the
outcome of interest in other words i had
to make a decision about lag times
so those are all the steps but what
different choices could i have made at
each of these steps so based on
the six data quality improvement
recommendations that i identified in
name one i came up with several
different data preparation choices that
might plausibly have been made and some
of those came from decisions other
researchers made in similar studies and
some came from consulting with dr erin
trimble at ohsu's adult cystic fibrosis
care center
and here's how the algorithm worked
so starting with step one the algorithm
randomly selected one of the three
methods for validating addresses so in
this example
um it selected one a from that first set
of steps and one is
to validate the patient zip codes using
a list of valid uh zip codes from the
united states postal service
um and then once it had completed that
transformation
then
the algorithm would move on to step two
and select one of the five methods for
handling missing addresses and transform
the data again using that method
and continuing to randomly select
methods from each step shown here
and transform the data according to that
selected method until
finally
the algorithm analyzed the prepared data
set in order to find the odds ratio for
the likelihood of a person with cystic
fibrosis
experiencing an exacerbation after being
exposed to ambient wildfire smoke
so in this case the combination of these
nodes 1a 2c 3c and 4a would produce a
statistically significant result that
tells us that a person with cystic
fibrosis has 1.3 times the odds of
experiencing a pulmonary exacerbation
after exposure to wildfire smoke
but this is only one of 135 possible
combinations of data preparation choices
that could have been made so in other
words there are 135 different pathways
through all the nodes and steps
so the algorithm would generate all
these data sets and then analyze them
using fisher's exact test
and this forest plot shows the resulting
unique odds ratios so some of the data
sets generated the same result
um and
that's why this only shows the 93
unique results
but my point here is that there's a lot
of variety right so the odds ratios
range from
0.83 to
2.93 which means that depending on how
that data was prepared there could be no
association between wildfire smoke and
exacerbations
and nearly three times the likelihood of
an exacerbation after wildfire smoke
exposure so keep in mind that the only
thing that i changed was these data
preparation choices i used the same
statistical test the same data set and i
even did the data preparation steps in
the same order
so clinicians give advice to their
patients based on research results like
this and
sometimes policy makers write
legislation based on research results
like this
and the choices that we make during data
preparation can have a huge impact on
these results
and we can
and they can make as much of a
difference as things that we're required
to disclose when we write up our
research like
which statistical test we use but
despite the importance of these data
preparation decisions we rarely talk
about them
so think about how much training you've
gotten on how to select a statistical
test
and then compare that to how much
training if any you've received on how
to select data preparation text
techniques
so with that in mind i wanted to examine
the variability in these results and
learn more about where that variability
might be coming from to see if any of
the data preparation choices in
particular might be responsible for that
so to look at that i used hedges g to
get the effect sizes that are shown here
and i calculated the effect size by
grouping the odds ratios together based
on which nodes they pass through and
that then i used the mean of those
grouped odds ratios
to calculate the standardized mean
difference using the equation shown here
at the bottom
which subtracts the mean of the grouped
odds ratio for each step from the mean
odds ratio for all results
and then divides up by the pooled
standard deviation
the equation for which is shown there
and
that part is called hedges g
so i thought that the different methods
for handling missing addresses would
have a stronger effect um but the
results showed otherwise and actually
the results showed that
exposure classification step 3 had
a
bigger effect size
and why is that um this swarm plot
illustrates how decisions about
exposure classification on node 3
can have a strong influence on which
patients are represented in the research
results which in turn can have a big
impact on those results
right so by making a choice to exclude
patients who live further away from the
air quality monitoring station you might
prevent
misclassifying people into the wrong
exposure category but it also excludes a
lot of people from the research data set
which kind of both has this big impact
on the result and it effectively creates
a research cohort that's entirely made
up of people who live in cities so that
choice would essentially trade one kind
of bias for another and as researchers
and data users we have to be mindful of
those trade-offs and we have to be
transparent about the representativeness
of our cohorts
okay so those are that's all that the
research part that i did
um now i'm going to kind of summarize
but
of course these three studies that i've
presented here today like all research
have some limitations
um like for the first study it's
important to note that although
some social determinants variables like
race and ethnicity might have more
thoroughly documented or easily
quantifiable data quality issues that
doesn't
necessarily mean that those variables
are of poor quality
having a larger body of research might
just indicate that these variables are
more accessible and therefore easier to
study
race and ethnicity for example are
available as demographic variables in
the ehr
they're relatively easier to pull
than say something like
patient socio-economic status
in the second study the provenance of
the data from the national code cohort
collaborative is limited which makes it
difficult to trace exactly how
errors occurred and in the third study
although my primary focus with
that research was ultimately not
epidemiological
um it's nonetheless likely that the
final study was
you know somewhat underpowered because
cystic fibrosis is a rare homeless
in terms of contributions
my first study connected the concepts of
data quality and bias and showed how
failure to identify and address those
data quality problems has the potential
to limit the validity and reliability of
efforts to understand and reduce health
inequity and it showed that the impact
of these data quality issues was not
equal across
all race races and ethnicities and i
identified a trend of problems with the
categorization of hispanic latino and
american indian or alaska native
patients
and my second paper showed that there
can be significant challenges with the
quality of race and ethnicity data in
large centralized databases my analysis
also called attention to issues with the
quality of some of the race and
ethnicity data in the national covid
cohort collaborative data enclave and
critically i demonstrated that data from
some of the very groups hardest hit by
the pandemic
american indians black or
african-americans and hispanic latinos
that data
is disproportionately affected by those
data quality problems so the n3c
has
since then set in motion a prop a
process
which promises to make available the
data on american indian patients that is
currently obscured
and i'm also
working with on another paper on ways
that some of the data that
was lost during that harmonization
process can be rescued
and
just as a general note with those
centralized multi-source databases i
feel like there's a lot of potential
there for the field of informatics to
make some really significant
contributions because we're still
hammering out how to make data sets like
that usable and we've only just
developed the capacity to store large
amounts of data very recently
and my final paper demonstrates
quantitatively that the conclusions that
we can draw from our research analysis
are highly dependent on how we prepare
the data
and although previous studies have
demonstrated the importance of data
preparation decisions to the field of
vermo
pharmaco epidemiology
to the best of my knowledge this is the
first study to show how these decisions
can impact the results of
social determinants of health research
so in conclusion
nearly everything we know about social
determinants of health and health equity
comes from studies conducted upon this
real world observational data
so if we want accurate insights into
health equity we need to pay attention
to the quality of the social
determinants data that we're analyzing
and i've shown that consideration of
data quality and thoughtfully applied
quality improvement methods might help
prevent bias i've demonstrated that
transparency about these numerous data
preparation decisions is critical if
researchers are going to make accurate
inferences from analyses and i hope my
hope is that you can open a dialogue
about how bias is introduced into data
and normalize the practice of reporting
data preparation techniques
so i want to thank all of my co-authors
for their help and for many hours of
brainstorming and i'd like to thank the
wonderful staff and faculty of ohsu
especially at dmicin in the library
um
and i'd also like to thank my fellow
students for their encouragement and
camaraderie
um
and
like to thank
dr karen eden who's the person who gave
me the
this opportunity in the first place um
and gave me the pep talks and
connections that i needed in order to
succeed um and i especially like to
thank my mentor dr nicole weiskopf who
just
constantly amazes me with her
intelligence um
and you know everything that i've
accomplished has been made so much
better
as a result of her feedback and her
input and
um
her impressive editing skills um and i'd
like to thank the members of my
committee for volunteering
their time to guide and educate me and
of course my loved ones some of which
are here today my parents and my son
otis and my boyfriend cheyenne so thank
you all
great
thank you
that was a very nice talk
i guess um i will
ask i'll lead off the questioning
actually i i'll lead off with a comment
which is um i actually realize um what i
told you yesterday about the the arrows
that one slide that i maybe was a little
too fixated on if you think about all
the common nor combinatorial
pathways through it there should be 135
unique uh pathways through that data so
so you don't need to fix that slide for
your nlm talk um but you know my um
question you know i i was originally as
you were talking about n3c i was
thinking oh my um you know this is
significant that there's this um you
know potential
um problems with n3c data although it
sounds like they're reacting to it but
but that then so actually maybe if you
could elaborate a little bit more on
that and and um how they plan to respond
to that but but then kind of really more
so looking forward um where do you see
as the biggest opportunities for present
for
using this kind of methodology to
improve other social determinants or
really all data in general
well yeah and i i'd like to emphasize
that this is a really like
relatively small like m3c is a huge
database so yeah it's 45 000 patients
but that's out of like millions so i
think it's all together we're talking
about less than one percent of the data
in their entire
database um yeah and and
they are moving to correct on the part
about american indians and kind of make
that data available again on obscurate
or come up with a mechanism that that
would allow for it to be unobscured
um
and in terms of the applications um like
i said i feel like these these really
large centralized databases are becoming
more and more common
and they do have a lot of those
heterogeneity issues when it comes to
harmonizing and mapping the data that
and i think we do need to kind of work
on how to make that work in order
you know to be able to get actionable
insights out of these databases because
they have so much potential you know to
have these um these national
nationwide databases but right now um
the data isn't as usable as it could be
and so i think informatics can kind of
contribute a lot in terms of mapping
those things and a lot of that has to do
with you know perfecting these
common data models and figuring out how
to
how best to take these like individual
encodings from different institutions
and be able to get them to
to talk to each other and
make sure they're
the same thing
um
so yeah a lot of it has to do with
data standards and
um
data models and try to figure out how
to get those to work together
great i'll let others um there we go
there's a commenter question in the chat
yeah so
so
nicole has a good point so there they
were the m3c chose to obscure the data
from
american indian alaska native patients
to protect the sovereignty
of the um
of those people so that they could have
control of their own data
and to be able to make decisions about
how their data was used
um
right so that the issue is more about
just making that data available and
um
yeah they're can't and to respond to it
um
mina said yeah there can be issues about
making data public
depending on the number of individuals
because they want to um obscure data
that is less than 20
individuals although that wasn't really
um
the issue
with this particular study
um it was more that those
some of those smaller categories hadn't
been rolled up into the larger main
categories in terms for researchers to
be able to use it and the
privacy issues are about you know taking
the data out of the n3c
itself
yeah does anybody else either looks like
chris has her hand up
okay yeah thanks lily really great
presentation i i thought it was really
important how you brought everything
back to effect sizes
and kind of walked us through you know
what your thinking was on that
i i'm curious this is my question is
around
the fact that
making a difference in the data you know
there's the absolute kind of what amount
of difference did it make but then
there's the question of whether it made
a positive
improvement in the data or kind of was
detrimental to the data like it's all
you know it's different but some of
those differences that you showed across
the board you know are
are things that might be viewed as bad
and others you know might be viewed as
better and and i wonder if there do you
have any feeling about
coupling that sense of how big the
effect is with
um any sense of how negative it is or
how positive it is in terms of what
happens
yeah that's a really good point so
essentially those effect sizes are kind
of like a measurement of variability and
not a judgment about like whether this
was good or bad it's just kind of like
well this
particular practice pushed
pushed the end result in this direction
um and so i think it's just like another
thing for
um data users to be aware of in terms of
like the choices that they make when
they're preparing data to be like all
right well this
could potentially have a pretty like
significant impact and this is this is
where we need to be most mindful about
the choices that we make right so in
other words like maybe the takeaway is
okay the effect sizes about classifying
exposures those have the biggest impact
so when we're choosing
to
to do that that's when we need to be
really really careful about the methods
that we choose
thank you really great
yeah does anybody else have anything
that they want to ask or any
comments that they want to make
oop michelle is our hand up hi lily
great talk um
so
i was wondering if you had any ideas
about
just what you were talking about you
know you identified that third step as
being the one that was crucial that had
the biggest potential impact on the
results of your data
but you know for most researchers
they're not going to create that tree of
all the different permutations of the
choices they made right
so um
do you have any more general
recommendations about how like you might
find that you might come across that
step like be able to identify that that
that third step had the biggest impact
without having to actually enumerate
every single
possible
um
you know path through all your choices
yeah so i don't necessarily think that
that's like um
something that every
you know
similar project should have to tend to
to do or run through but i do feel like
um there needs to be kind of a body of
research about these methods with
regards to observational data like as
we're getting to the point where we have
this data is more available and we're
using it a lot more
and we're stepping away
more from those kind of uh traditional
like
clinical
controlled randomized controlled trial
types of studies and and going more
towards using these observational real
world data
that we need you know informatics and we
need researchers to kind of look into
this and to to
to
tell
these people who are using this data
like look this is what you need to do so
not necessarily that that particular
method needs to be reproduced by
every single researcher who's using
observational data but there does need
to be a body of research available to
data users that they can look at and say
like okay like this is where we need to
be careful
as we go through like this data
preparation process or or as we
um you know analyze these things
so that's kind of my hope that there'll
be this bigger body of evidence
available
for data users
great thanks
so the call to follow up on miss shell's
question and do you think effect size
should be something you should be
looking at when you make the decision of
what to explore the quality on
um
yeah i'm not
sure if i you know that's kind of like a
i'm kind of making up my own techniques
like at this point because um
because this area is so new so yeah i
don't know if i would necessarily do
that next time but again it's really
helpful for kind of understanding
variability and um what the most
important or most sensitive parts of the
data preparation process might be
um i don't know if it would apply
outside of
those integrated data sets or outside of
environmental health research but you
know i'd like the opportunity certainly
to try it with other
data sets and with other studies to see
what would happen and to see if it might
be generalizable in that way
and i'd certainly encourage like if
anybody wants to
try to reproduce it and and to try to do
that same thing with the effect sizes
and see if it's
something that could be useful in
different areas like i think that would
be
great and i'm happy to
share the code and everything which is
in this
it's in the appendix of my dissertation
write-up so something i want to make
available to people to try to do on
their own
um
yeah i agree with what mina says about
yeah we kind of need to incorporate
people with
subject
expertise and
imputation expertise and
data science expertise too
okay does anybody else have any
questions
okay well if
um
we the public can can leave um
lily to her committee
and they will carry out the next steps
so thank you again lily for a great
presentation and
thank you everyone for attending today